okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of science
and technology
i'm happy to try and uh
tell you about things i know both from
my personal experience of
the last i don't know 50 or so years of
science and technology or things that
i've studied for other reasons
i see a whole bunch of questions that
have been sent in
or left over
so let me see what i can address first
let's run from streamer what happened
with computers during world war two
well i'm gonna have to do a little bit
of memory
uh
work here and let me make sure i get all
the dates right
but
let me let me talk a little bit about
this sort of the overall picture of
computers and computing
um
electronic computers digital electronic
computers of the kind we
now routinely have
basically came into existence after
world war ii
uh anyak for example
first big big one in the u.s
was like 1946.
um
it was
and and so what did computer mean before
that time
well
first thing is that more common than
computer within er was compute or with
an or a person who would compute things
and that was
a
serious and important profession
was just being able to compute things
and so there were many places
where
computing of that type was important so
um
for example ballistics tables
um i think the any act was originally
developed in connection with the
aberdeen proving ground
and
which is a ballistics um question of
ballistics so i mean the basic issue is
you're
going to shoot a shell
you know 10 miles or something
from a very big gun
and it's going to go in a roughly
parabolic trajectory
but
exactly where is it going to land
when you take into account air
resistance wind
the rotation of the earth all these
kinds of things
that turns out to be a problem that is
hard to compute and for which there was
a great desire to have
uh more efficient methods of computation
people typically use tables that have
been pre-computed to do those ballistics
computations um before there were
electronic computers to do them and uh
the the first computers of that type
were developed to produce the tables but
let me go back a little bit in history
um
so
uh mechanical computers
had existed
uh
from
well the earliest example we know is the
antikythera device from around first
century bc to first century a.d but it's
a it's an outlier it's the only one of
those we know in antiquity
um the uh kind of
mechanical computers which are
essentially like odometer-like wheels
that you could use for addition or
multiplication
uh and so on
those started to be developed in the
mid-1600s
um so 1640-ish
pascal
um
famously had an early such thing i think
it was a chap called chicag who's the
earliest known example
uh person who interacted with kepler and
built i think was a wooden device which
has not survived the pascal devices is
made of metal and did survive
and a lot of other people got into the
act you know gottfried leibniz for
example late 1600s uh spent 30 years
trying to
to perfect kind of a four function
uh plus minus times divides uh kind of
you know mechanical computer made of
brass you can actually see the thing
that he made
in his archive in hanover
um
but uh
there was sort of steady improvement of
mechanical computers
and when i was a kid for example
uh mechanical computers were still a
thing you know electronic calculators
came in around 1972
and before that time
there were uh you know if you were sort
of a
sophisticated you've got to use um uh
if you were very sophisticated you got
to use electronic computers uh big
electronic computers but if you were a
little bit
like a a
sort of an advanced kid so to speak you
might use or somebody in a in an office
or something you might very well use a
mechanical calculator um and uh where
you were you know turning a wheel and
you were setting things and and um uh
you were setting essentially cogs and
then
turning things and and numbers were
popping out and so on um
that was kind of mechanical calculators
was kind of the state of the art
um up until
well big computers came in
in the 1950s to 1960s
calculators came in in the beginning of
1970s 1972 or so
uh personal computers
came in in the beginning of the 80s um
so
for
uh you know the earlier version of
computers
um people were at best using mechanical
calculators which at best could do plus
minus times divides now the other
standard method of computation with
slide rules
um i think i have a slightly sometimes
i can't get it right now but but um
slide rules were invented back in the
1600s along with the invention of
logarithms
um i think they were invented uh the
chapter william outread who was a um
also the person who invented a
multiplication sign
uh which famously leiden it said it was
a really bad idea because it looks like
an x and people are going to get it
confused but um anyway it survived
anyway but a slide rule again when i was
a kid that was the standard way that you
computed if you didn't have this sort of
big mechanical metal calculator the the
next best thing was a slide rule where
you're using logarithmic uh using the
fact that logarithms when you add
logarithms that corresponds to
multiplication to be able to do
multiplication and division and a fancy
slide rule would have many different
scales you know there was a c scale and
d scale which were the main two scales
used for multiplication
um and then there were all kinds of
other scales that would have
trigonometric functions and
um sometimes other quite different kinds
of computations encoded in those
schedule scales and i think a sort of
typical somewhat fancy slide rule might
have had uh i don't know 10 scales on
the front and 10 scales on the back
um so anyway that was kind of the state
of the art for calculating things uh
it's kind of the hierarchy of either you
did it by pure pencil and paper or using
a slide rule or you use a mechanical
calculator um
and
in world war ii
that was
the state of the art
and um
you would uh so
ballistics tables were one place where
computations were done
um
the nuclear weapons development the
manhattan project was another big place
where they were done
another place where they were done was
some aerodynamics calculations i think
famously the wings of the spitfire
fighter were def were were designed um
using an early version of the final
finite difference method for solving uh
partial differential equations
um
actually no relaxation method for doing
that um because you essentially was
solving i think that was a essentially
solving laplace's equation numerically
um but in any case the
the um
uh
in for example the manhattan project
uh there was a whole
uh
group of people who were computers
who were uh
working out
different kinds of things and actually
my my friend dick feynman a former
friend dick feynman um
who
uh
was
his his job at los alamos one of his
main jobs was running
i'm not sure if the whole part of the of
the pool of computers
um who were doing those kinds of uh
calculations
and
people developed uh i would say that the
um
um
in those days the computers
uh were mostly women um mostly uh
um and uh and that that actually
continued when the first programmers um
were um originally programming
electronic computers it was it was
primarily a
a
uh
it was very much weighted in in the in
the the female direction
and um something that we're finally
seeing come back with the
the current generation of um
uh of programmers i think but it's
taking a long time
in any case the um uh
the thing that um
um
was uh so so you ask about computers in
world war ii
um
the
the dominant form of computation were
these uh were these non-digital
electronic computer type methods
now
in terms of what was being developed
during world war ii
there's sort of a certain amount of some
things that are a bit shrouded in
mystery
um but there are a few things one knows
one certainly knows about the
development of
essentially electromechanical computers
at bletchley park in england for code
breaking
and the problem there was that one
needed to
uh
in order to break those codes one had to
evaluate many different possible
passwords many different possible keys
and the question was how quickly could
you check whether these keys were
plausible and by plausible one meant did
they uh sort of uh decode a message
into good german or would they decode a
message with that key into gobbled
letters that couldn't possibly have been
an original message
and so there was this computer called
the bomb the ombe that was developed at
bletchley park it's a kind of special
purpose computer whose objective was to
just step through different possible
keys and see which ones worked
and that computer was very much based on
uh telephone switching technology
uh that had been another kind of branch
is it this is a complicated history
actually the um
um
in the development of computers
okay i i should explain a little bit of
of the of the history there were
mechanical computers
and
there was sort of a a push to think
about could we automate the operation of
a mechanical computer of a mathematical
calculation mechanical computer could we
make that electronic that was what led
eventually to the eniac
um
the uh there was sort of a big
innovation which was the stored program
computer where instead of just having to
set up with kind of a plug board of
wires or some other method um
set up in hardware what computation one
wanted to do it was possible to in
effectively store in the memory of the
computer
um a specification of the program and
then execute it and that was the thing
that that um uh came in
and there was a chap with john atanasso
who was a physicist in iowa
who was um uh involved in what what may
have been sort of the first stored
program computer
um around the
around maybe the
uh
1940-ish maybe that kind of time frame
um
it's always confusing because i grew up
in england where the the dates of world
war ii 1939 to 1945 um in the u.s
they're obviously different
um 1942 i guess to 1945. um so when
people say during world war ii
they um the dates are um uh uh the
different dates that one thinks of in
any case the um so one branch of the
development of computers had to do with
let's let's automate
the
mechanical calculators so to speak
another branch of um
uh computing had to do with the
computers that were used for
for example um
cryptography cryptanalysis like the
bombs of bletchley park which were a
little bit more special purpose they
were not intended to automate
mathematical calculation they were
intended to automate this process of
stepping through these different
possible keys
and as i say they were using technology
that had been developed for the
electronic switching system for
telephones where you know back when
telephones were first around you know
120 years ago or something now
um
they um uh that was the thing where
where um
um
the
faster ringing in the background it's
very curious um
okay
um
it doesn't stop
um
well gosh
if it really doesn't stop i suppose i
can stop it
no it stopped um
in any case the um
uh
uh what was i saying i was saying that
that um uh back when when telephones
were first around
you would pick up your phone
and you would get
uh
it was sort of a direct electrical
connection to the operator
who would then
take sort of the wire that was coming
from your phone and have a plug board
where they would connect one wire to
another uh to another you know your your
output to another input and that's the
way that you would be connected to
another
uh person so to speak
and
then
when people started having long distance
phone calls and things it became quite
unrealistic to have somebody just sort
of plug these together and so i don't
actually know the whole history of this
but but um i guess it was called std
standard trunk dialing and i think trunk
dialing had to do with the idea that you
would have these trunks which were
collections of wires
that and you would be able to do things
where you would instead of just saying
i want to directly connect to my friend
jim or something who's at this number
that the you know where one wire could
connect to another wire you were
connecting into a trunk which would then
go to another uh another exchange
uh where there will be another
connection made and so on it kind of i
think is reminiscent of the early days
of email for example you know in today's
world and you would just say you know
uh whatever at something at wilton.com
or something as a as an email address
but back when
email was was young
uh
the um back it even in the in the well
in the 80s were not when i used email um
the uucp the unix to unix copy system
was kind of a a main way of doing email
wasn't the only way but it was a
main important way of doing email and
what you would do there is you would say
literally the route of the email should
follow you'd say one machine x time
another machine x time another machine
and it would like one machine would call
the next machine would call the next
machine and so on going down the line
and i think that's more what was
happening with this kind of exchange to
exchange type of thing but anyway that
whole
mechanism of getting sort of automated
dialing of automation of dialing led to
a kind of automation which is what was
used for for example the bom computers
in um i'm not sure when we really call
them a computer they're very special
purpose kind of computers
now
uh
in
one thing that's missing from my story
here is what about all the theoretical
work that was done like alan turing's
1936
paper on universal computers or ml
work on
on string manipulation systems or alonzo
church's lambda calculus uh or moses
schoenfinkel's combinators back from
1920
what happened to those things
how did they relate to the actual
computers that were being built the
answer is they didn't really relate um
one could have imagined computers that
were based on string manipulation maybe
even an explicit implementation of a
turing machine but that isn't what
people built what people built was much
more in the line of sort of automate the
mechanical calculators and it took kind
of a the the kind of work on neural nets
by mcculloch and pitts in 1943 or so um
and then john von neumann kind of being
interested both in brains
and in computing machines to kind of
bring together the tradition of sort of
turing machines and theoretical
computation together with a sort of
practical let's actually have an adder
and a multiplier built into our computer
um kind of computation
so
uh those
there were actually early proposals i i
recently learned that haskell curry who
is the person who really uh
well spent spent a career working on
combinators these very simple basis for
computation that moses sean finkel had
invented in 1920 that people hadn't
really understood very well then and
pretty much ever since
i wrote a book about those things
actually in
in 2020 in sort of celebration of the
1920 uh
invention of those things and there's
lots more one could say about them today
but there's no question that they are
very abstract and in many ways very
obscure and not a good sort of human way
to present computation
but in any case
curry's work
on combinators led him among other
things to start suggesting i gather
functional programming kinds of ideas
very early on in in the in the days when
the eniac was being developed it's not
clear people understood it's not
completely clear he completely
understood uh some of what can now be
done in those directions and of course
lambda calculus have been invented in
1935 that's sort of a a fundamental
thing used in uh in functional
programming but that didn't enter kind
of the world of practical programming
for a very long time that was very much
a theoretical kind of thing
now there's one additional piece
to this whole picture
uh that people sometimes bring up
um there are sort of where else were
computers invented it's a chap called
conrad zuza
who
did work on computers
presumably during world war ii
and and then subsequently had a company
in germany called zuza ag
that made computers and um
uh
was uh and that i think stayed in
existence certainly through the 1970s
uh conrad zouza uh was kind of a um
uh
i would say a um
not only a practical build computers
kind of person but also a um
uh what's kind of the the theory of what
one can do with computation a little bit
at least i mean he got interested in
whether one could sort of have physics
be ultimately computational and i
actually exchanged letters with him in
the early 1980s because he'd gotten
interested in the things i'd done about
cellular automata and so on he had a
kind of a model
in which
space was divided into discrete cells
and somehow at every cell there would be
a number and it's very much more like a
finite difference
kind of uh different
version of differential equations than a
true cellular automaton where you're
forcing yourself to have a discrete
value at every cell as well as to have
discrete cells but any case he was
interested in those kinds of things but
there's a there's an interesting piece
to this tale
uh in 1944 or so
uh conrad zouza
uh apparently developed
a a binary mechanical computer
um
and uh
perhaps the first kind of um uh binary
computer that had been produced
but
it's a it's a very interesting entangled
tale
what
the real story of that computer was
um
and i've tried a little bit to track
this down
it's a little bit mired in kind of
national pride i mean it's like when i
was a kid and you said where would when
was where was television invented i
always learned the television event was
invented by a scottish chap called baird
but i think in the u.s one learns that
it was invented by an american i think
in russia one learns it was invented by
a russian in france by a french person
and so on um so i think that um there is
a certain uh when it comes to computers
there can be also a certain national
pride factor um because the the true
quotes invention of the computer was a
somewhat long drawn out kind of thing it
wasn't like a particular moment when
sort of everything that we think of as a
modern computer was invented but anyway
one of the sort of pieces of that
uh was this work done by connor azuza
and i'll tell you what i i think i know
about this i mean there were um a
collection of um
computers
um produced
by
i say computer it's a mechanical
calculating device
um that happened to use binary
um
and uh uh
there is in at least there was
close to ten years ago now there at
least was
a reproduction
of this computer in the museum in berlin
and um
uh
i remember i visited there once and and
i actually met with both the
the curator who've been responsible for
this and conrad zouzo's son for zuza
um
and uh
the you know there's this computer and
it was reconstructed by hors suzer and
conrad zuza you know many many years
after the computer had originally
existed and it's there in the museum or
it was there in the museum
and it's like how do you know what the
computer was like
and the answer was there was one
photograph of the computer
and
um that was apparently taken in 1944 or
so
um
and uh the computer in the photograph
actually didn't look much like the
computer that was in the museum but sort
of it was it had been sort of flattened
out and turned around and so on
so perhaps it was the same kind of kind
of structure
but i think some of it may have been
kind of
uh almost by memory 30 years later so
i'm not sure how how reliable that will
have been
but the real question that i had was
this is a computer made of metal
what happened to it
it was you know you can't just you know
it's a big object made of metal
um
stainless steel actually
what um
what became of the computer
well what i had heard
was that the computer had been in a
house the the house of grenadiers
parents
in berlin and that the house was bombed
in in world war ii
and the computer was destroyed
but so then i i was like but but you
know
a house is bombed what actually happens
to a computer a big hunk of metal
in a house that's bombed
and um
the
the answer
seemed quite obscure
because it was like well where was the
computer was the computer you know on
the third floor of the house was it in
the basement of the house
uh what happens to a big chunk of steel
if a house collapses on top of it
you know what what was the whole story
and and the question that i asked right
there was where is this house
well the answer is it was about five
blocks from there unfortunately i had to
go catch a plane but i could have
investigated even at the time but it was
a about five blocks from there or
something and it was just on the western
side of where the berlin wall had been
in an area that had been rather a a kind
of gumpy area but have been
coming up in the world um since the fall
of the berlin wall
but in any case the the question then
was well okay what happens to a computer
that
is you know where was the computer in
the house
well it was thought to be in the
basement okay if it's in the basement a
house maybe collapses on top of it uh
but that means it's sort of an
archaeology problem and so i
subsequently asked some people i know
who've done urban archaeology um what
what would you find what would happen in
this case and they were like well it'll
be there you know something will be
there it may have been squashed and
crushed and things but it'll be there um
and uh if it and and so then
there's a question of okay uh
the the the people who i asked about
urban archaeology did say urban
archaeology is a complicated thing to do
because there are all kinds of permits
and ownership questions
and they said often the people don't
want you to find the stuff that you
would find with urban archaeology
and um so
i over the over the years i've i've
occasionally made inquiries about the
zusa computer and what really happened
to it and it kind of
you know first it was like it was in
this house and when it was the address
of the house actually was two houses
next to each other
and in germany uh the property records
are not public so it's not easy to just
sort of look up what the what the
ownership history of that house has been
um but uh
then then it was like well well let's
you know we did find out something about
this house and then well actually maybe
it isn't in the house maybe it's in this
underneath this park that's next to the
house
and then well actually maybe it was an
airaid shelter that was somewhere
different that had been moved to
and somehow the computer has been on the
move but it's never been found and i
have to say i think it would be very
interesting to find this computer i do
think that there are questions about
uh both
well there are questions about what one
would find if one found the computer for
example it's not obvious
uh where
how you get big hunks of metal during
world war ii in you know late in world
war ii in berlin
um and there's sort of probably a a
complicated tale of where that metal
came from and sort of how militarily
related the computer really was i mean
the original claim had been that uh zuzo
was a
just a student and just building this
computer for fun
people have told me
a series of different people have told
me all kinds of tales i'm afraid not the
tales don't completely fit together so
i'm not sure they're worth repeating
because they don't really um uh
they don't really um uh sort of connect
um
the uh about um
so the relationship of zuza to the um uh
german air force particularly and um
other parts of the german sort of state
apparatus at that time anyway so that's
a that's a mystery out there that's a
sort of history of computing mystery
that's still out there it probably will
eventually be resolved i'm afraid um uh
there are still people around um i
talked to one chap in his 90s who had
been who
had been a user of the zuza computers
and so on um the electronic ones that
have been produced after world war ii um
and uh
uh
but i'm afraid it's you know time is
sort of running out in terms of people
who had first-time knowledge of some of
these things um but uh
you know there's still the archaeology
when that fails
okay let's see
um that was a very long answer sorry to
to that question
um
so questions are okay all sorts of
interesting things
um parmese's comments that imitation
game is a it's a great movie about
computers in world war ii i have to say
that that movie
uh frustrated me because it's a really
good movie as a movie and it's a really
inaccurate rendering of the history it's
a movie that purports to be about alan
turing
and his adventures at bletchley park
during world war ii and it has some
beautiful reproductions of things like
the bomb computers at bletchley park and
kind of great set design and so on but
the actual screenplay
is
paints a
picture of alan turing that is
completely inaccurate so far as i can
tell i mean it paints a picture of a
kind of confident arrogant um
uh
uh sort of chap
who and that's not
what people who knew alan turing have
told me he was like at all
um and uh much more nerdy much more
kind of um uh very very different from
the way it's portrayed in that movie
so it was kind of interesting because
the at about the same time a few years
ago the imitation game movie came out
and um
oh gosh what was it called the movie
about stephen hawking
um oh what was it called
maybe theory of everything i'm not sure
um
came out and uh i would say as
you know pure movie critic movie making
the imitation game movie about about han
turing was a more uh sort of more a
better movie as movie
um but the the stephen hawking movie was
a vastly more accurate movie i mean i
had in fact known stephen hawking at
roughly the the
more or less the time period a little
bit after the time period that that
movie uh was covering and uh it seemed
pretty accurate and pretty good um
rendering of um and actually i'd known
there were all sorts of physicists
something portrayed in that movie most
of whom i i i knew or had or had known
and i would say that that movie from
what i know was a pretty accurate movie
but less
less good entertainment value so to
speak than the imitation game
um so it goes i mean this is this is one
of the sort of trade-offs of um
uh of movies i in the times i've helped
with movies and things and you know you
try and inject some science or
historical accuracy or something and um
but you have to be aware of the fact
that the arc of the story as far as the
making of an entertaining movie is
probably more important than the
accuracy of uh you know is that exactly
the right thing to say scientifically or
whatever else
um
there's a question here
on um
uh
from philip
how important are nobel prizes are there
any scandalous or missions
you know
one thing i say about prizes in general
is
by the time a field has a prize for it
the field is already sufficiently well
developed
that the most exciting things have
already been done
not quite true but it's often true i
mean in in things that um
for example i've been involved in
inventing you know eventually
they're sort of prizes for those kinds
of fields but that's the time in the
field it's very well developed when it's
just being invented nobody has a prize
for a field that doesn't even have a
name yet
so in
the nobel prize i would say that um
uh
it's a it's a funny thing because
it is
a
at the time when the prize was
introduced by alfred nobel
um
inventor of dynamite if i remember
correctly
um
the um
the prize was notable for being more
money than anybody had ever seen a prize
be
um so it was immediately kind of very
famous in the world and i know it had a
lot of sort of special treatment like i
i remember the us tax code used to have
an ex special exception for nobel prizes
not being taxable actually i'm i'm
wondering whether that's still there
because i i remember commenting on that
to a friend of mine who just won a nobel
prize maybe
15 years ago or something and i'm not
sure that clause was still there even at
that time but it had been there
um certainly was there 30 years ago
um so it was you know considered to be a
very sort of special prize
and um
because of the amount of money involved
there was subsequently other kinds of
prizes which people which are not nearly
as sort of famous in popular culture but
which end up being at least as much
money
and i think
the uh
originally
there are lots of scoreless things said
about the original development of the
nobel prize and and kind of
sort of alfred nobel and you know prizes
prizes one has to realize as a practical
matter are often as much
uh for the benefit of the giver as they
are for the benefit of the recipient so
to speak and i think this was sort of a
pr
induced um uh prize
idea
and uh the the original nobel prizes are
sort of sweden-based and then there are
extra ones like the peace prize and so
on which are and the economics prize
which i think are norway based if i'm
remembering correctly but the original
ones the original alfred nobel ones
uh sort of physics chemistry physiology
medicine
uh my forgetting one i think that's it
notably there isn't a mathematics one
the um the gossip claim is
that um a chap called gustav mitte
mittag lefla who is a famous um swedish
mathematician
um had some romantic involvement with
nobel's wife again this is this is
gossip i don't i have not gone and
tracked down the history of this well
and that um nobel
was kind of like i'm not gonna give a
prize for mathematics um
you know because
that scoundrel metagro will will
inevitably win it
and so so that's why there was sort of
no nobel prize for for mathematics
um so that so the gossip goes
uh
you know i think in the early years
of nobel prizes
there was some
uh kind of
well
there was a sort of golden okay physics
was in exactly the state that i might
describe it as being a sort of
well-developed field where well there
was incremental progress but
but you know
nothing too dramatic was happening um
right around the time when the nobel
prize was was introduced but then
uh sort of
you know the kind of golden age of
relativity and quantum mechanics and so
on started developing and suddenly
physics was very exciting and so there
are
plenty of sort of famous nobel prizes i
mean i think there were some early nobel
prizes there was one given for some kind
of lighthouse invention that was um uh
where it's like uh they've kind of run
out of things to you know dramatic
developments in physics by the time
that's what this physics prize is is
going to but then physics woke up again
and so the nobel prize ended up being
something that made made some more sense
for for a number of years
and you know i think that it is
interesting because
there's sort of a um
uh
uh uh
the
the sort of theoretical nobel prizes for
theoretical developments and then there
are practical ones
and for a while
it was like they were holy there was the
whole series like everybody who'd
invented a kind of particle detector
eventually won a nobel prize so to speak
where they were kind of methodological
prizes or instrumentation prizes more so
than sort of conceptual prizes or
theoretical prizes and i think there was
long kind of a a belief
well you know it can't really be a pure
theoretical prize it's got to be sort of
something where
the thing was sort of reduced to
practice and somebody actually observed
that effect and so on you know in the
early days of the nobel prize in the
sort of theory versus other things it's
often quoted that you know when einstein
won his uh sort of very much expected
nobel prize it was for the photoelectric
effect not for relativity because at the
time relativity was still sort of
theoretical and controversial and the
photoelectric effect was something you'd
go out and measure and see that yes that
was it really worked that way so to
speak
um i think that uh
in
i must admit
that with some exceptions
i
have
uh the
you know as different fields have gone
up and down in an energy level so to
speak the prices have been more and less
interesting i mean even in physics for
example
it's i always
uh
it's always a bit funny when i when i
see the you know the latest nobel prize
announcement i've never heard of people
who are winning it and i really do
follow physics and have done for many
many years
but it's
you know
that's
often for things like instrumentation
which is something i don't follow as
such and where often the names of the
people are not as widely known as the as
the instruments they've created and so
on
um in you know in recent years sort of
biology has been a big kind of area
because it's a very hot field you know
and there have been things in physics
like gravitational wave discovery which
was a real sort of uh you know old style
nobel prize type story so to speak
um
i think the uh there's also the question
of you know what does it do to a field
when there's a prize that people think
is really worth winning
um i'm not sure how
uh when i was doing physics in the
1970s and early 1980s
it was kind of like people would always
say oh well if you do that you know
you'll eventually win a nobel prize type
thing and that's you know then you've
really made it kind of thing um i'm not
sure that that's a great
feature for a field
i've certainly seen people
uh for whom that's been a very negative
thing you know i'm reminded i haven't
thought about this for ages i remember
when i was a kid and it must have been
oh when was it probably
early 1970s because i remember it was on
yeah black and white television i
remember seeing some
some
movie type thing
whose title was how to win a nobel prize
i'm sure in the modern days one could
just look it up and it's somewhere on
youtube but i remember it it had it was
kind of funny it had a it was a um uh
you know the fact that was being
broadcast on british television
tells what i don't know what it tells
one but um uh
different perhaps a different kind of
programming than one would normally find
today
but um it was uh uh
it had sort of these amusing little
little segments and it had sort of a
card that came up at the end of each
segment and one of the cards was don't
die
um
or don't die too quickly because you
know it pointed out you know the the
average time from a discovery being made
to the you know prize being given i
don't remember at all what the what the
answer was but you know 30 years or
something like this
and it had um
i think it had other ones it was like um
uh
i don't remember it's been a long time
it was probably a
don't nominate yourself
and there's a um uh there were some
other ones which were kind of um a
little bit more hard to arrange so to
speak um uh kinds of uh kinds of
concepts but the the don't die ones one
that um i sort of remember as a as a as
a conclusion there um and that's sort of
you know that there's been a certain
sense of
of some kinds of
uh
there's been a certain oh you know that
thing happened but that was 40 years ago
and oh they're just around getting
around to giving the prize now that's
old hat type thing
so but any case in terms of the the
dynamics of a field where the nobel
prize is like a an important thing
which
i think
it is more important in some places than
in others
um
i think that uh
uh
somehow
in um in economics it's almost like
every any economist i've ever heard of
has got a nobel prize sometime or
another and um uh it's um
uh and that's i don't know what what you
know there's probably some dynamics that
have to do with the different sizes of
fields and things like this
but
um
in in physics where i know it in a bit
more detail
uh
there are
i would say there's the sort of the
worst case is people who made a
discovery which they were like well this
should win a nobel prize
and then they waited
for years and decades
and eventually they got their nobel
prize at least in one case that i'm
thinking of in particular
and um
it seemed like a whole lifetime was
spent waiting for a nobel prize
um
in the end
um
the person
uh involved as a friend of mine um
it's uh
um
the um uh you know in the end i happened
to drop in on him and on his office
shelf was this box of sort of nobel
stuff a cardboard box and i was like
well did it actually turn out to be
exciting it was like oh not really it
was kind of you know the parties were
kind of fun but it wasn't uh
it wasn't that exciting type thing
um
i think that the um
uh you know there have been other cases
um
oh for example um
cases where they've been
endless sort of uh maneuvering for you
know who will get the prize for what i
mean i certainly
i know plenty of cases where people
spent you know ages doing sort of
scientific politicking of uh
uh you know always mention me in
connection with this so that um i'm part
of the story of the prize i'm thinking
of at least
three major examples of that um and and
then there were cases uh you know one i
could mention was um benoit mandelbrot
the um inventor of fractals and so on
who
was quite obsessed with the idea that he
should win some nobel prize
whichever one was available so to speak
so first it was the physics prize then
he kind of segued to kind of going for
the economic surprise and maybe there
was even a chemistry play in the middle
of that and i remember actually now that
i'm thinking about it back in 1984 i was
at a a conference that was put on by the
nobel foundation
um
that was i don't think it had anything
to do with the nobel prize i just think
it happened to be the same foundation
that was putting it on um although
probably a bunch of the people in fact
yeah i remember talking to some of the
people who were there who were part of
the swedish academy of sciences and and
part of the sort of nobel prize
apparatus
but this particular conference had no
particular nobel prize character to it
so to speak um but anyway i was there
and my mantelbot was also there and i
was young in those days um benoit was
not quite so young
um but benoit was like you know at every
possible opportunity was kind of um uh
sort of um canvassing for a physics
nobel prize and it's like
why do you care
you know it's like like
nobody you know fractals are important
and they will be remembered
and
nobody will know or care whether the
person who invented them won a nobel
prize or didn't
it's the the prize pales in comparison
to the actual discovery and that's
that's usually the case for for
significant discoveries
and i think um
but
you know for
but i think i mean my own feeling is
that
prizes are a complicated piece of
tactics for a field
as i say prizes are often as a practical
matter much more for the benefit of the
giver than for the benefit of the
recipient
um and uh but even if you sort of
consider the cases where prizes have
been set up for the purpose of guiding a
field it's a complicated issue i mean i
have set up a few prizes myself
for specific problems and projects
that i'd like to see solved and one in
particular a 2-3 touring machine prize
from 2007 that was a big success because
uh young chap called alex smith
um you know i put up the prize and four
months later it solved it i have another
one for rule 30 various features of rule
30 that we put up in 2018 or 2019
which uh is still very much open and
another one for s combinator
universality that was from uh 2020 or
2021 actually
um and
that um i'm a little bit afraid that
those prizes will remain open for
hundreds of years um and
that's always a risk but at least
they're very specific kinds of things
aim to kind of highlight
the the value i believe of solving
particular kinds of scientific problems
uh rather than kind of more of a
an after the fact kind of uh that was
cool type thing
um
so
uh
the um okay i see somebody
apparently said that the nobel prize is
taxable income now it definitely wasn't
because i remember seeing that very
lying when i first moved to the us i
remember seeing that very line in the
tax returns
and
certainly by the rules as i understand
them today would be taxable income i
remember that in the um
uh
when i
got one of these macarthur fellowship
things in 1981
uh that was a time when it was still the
case that if somebody just gave you
a a thing gave you money and you didn't
have to do anything for it
then that still didn't count to
something taxable and that loophole was
subsequently uh subsequently removed
uh at least largely so um
the uh
yeah philip is commenting that some
nobel prizes have been a bit random
pension wilson
this he says um got the price of
discovering the cosmic microwave
background but george gamoff who
predicted it
um got nothing i was gamoff still alive
and so the the cosmic microarray
background was discovered around 1964
um
and as sort of a a um
uh
it was kind of a um
a chance discovery because
these folks at bell labs
um
and uh
i certainly uh met ono penzias
who was became a sort of senior manager
at labs uh subsequently um
the um
they were trying to do
early satellite communications because
there were now satellites by 1964 or so
and um
the uh they wanted to set up an antenna
that would be a very high gain antenna
that would be um uh
picking up you know even very
small satellite signals and they
discovered they just kept on seeing
noise
in this um
their antenna kept on
um picking up uh radio noise
and um
uh
that was um it was eventually realized
that there was this 2.7 kelvin
background radiation that was being
being detected there
um but um and then it was rather quickly
figured out
in those days
people weren't sure about the early
the the origins of the universe and
there were really two competing theories
the the big bang theory that said it all
started from a a small sort of hot thing
and then expanded outward and the steady
state theory
that said that gradually new matter was
coming to into existence the universe
was expanding by virtue of new matter
kind of popping into existence in
different places around the universe
and fred hoyle in particular was very
much uh who was a
british
cosmologist who i unfortunately never
met
um the uh who um
i was very was sort of the
the ascendant figure hit there
and he had um
said it's uh the steady state theory is
the thing in fact i think he coined the
term big bang as a kind of put down to
this alternative theory that it all
started in a big bang so to speak but i
think it was very very quick when the
cosmic microwave background
um
was uh or what was originally called the
microwave background radiation um
was uh
was discovered i think it was
surprisingly quick that people realized
that that was probably left over
radiation from the big bang
and that had been a thing that um
george gamoff who'd been a nuclear
physicist
uh had
sort of predicted he was um
involved in early
ideas
about um the production of um of
elements in the early universe through
nuclear reactions and so on um and uh
i think um
um
uh
i i never met george gamoff i'm not even
sure
um
how long he lived i think he was at
university of colorado in the end
um
he was famous for such little gags as
some
uh there's a
theory to do with it nuclear alpha decay
and um it was a paper
by a person called alpha
phr
um
beta hence beta b-e-t-h-e
and gamma
g-a-m-o-w
and um that was they were you know i
think i think they they may have even
added an author to that paper just to
make it the alpha beta gamma
uh type type paper i think gamoff was
then involved in lots of other kind of
exported physics kind of ideas
um including
questions about the genetic code and
things like that which i think didn't
work out perfectly in the end
um he also wrote a number of
uh fun popular books about relativity
and another thing i think he i think he
wrote an autobiography called something
like um my worldline
playing on the kind of relativity uh uh
notion of that if i'm remembering
correctly
any case
um
yeah well so the
it's um
uh
on the
yeah one of the things that um
um
people
you know depending on how you define
sort of the the the prized domain so to
speak people regularly send me things
saying you know look the instrumentation
that you've produced for physics namely
mathematica and so on is you know has
been a really important thing in the
history of physics and it's like
but
i certainly wouldn't you know it's like
from my point of view of the definition
of sort of physics prizes
you know this is tooling so to speak but
i guess it's
it's no more or less tooling than
something like a bubble chamber
um
let's see
um
there's a question here
about
from diana
about
uh
when and why did apprenticeships end
seems like lots of great people were
apprentices
um
and she mentions benjamin franklin i
actually yes i guess i did know that
that piece of the story
apprenticeships
well still exist in many for many
practical purposes although they're not
usually called apprenticeships but the
concept i think of apprenticeships was
something that was really big
when there were guilds and when there
was this whole kind of hierarchy of you
know first you joined a um
some you know blacksmith or something as
an apprentice
and then you became i'm not sure of the
sequence i think journeyman was one
piece of it and eventually you became a
a sort of full guild member blacksmith
it was kind of a process of
first you're kind of working with the
person and then you kind of gradually
advance to the point where you can take
over their job
well
for example the way that a lot of
academia works
and this concept of kind of graduate
students
who will be the kind of
the apprentices so to speak uh to the
the professors it's not really quite
defined that way and things worked a bit
differently and the history of
universities was a little bit different
in terms of the way that was set up
because universities didn't really the
concept of research
as kind of a a key mission of
universities
is a comparatively recent phenomenon in
many ways um i mean in in the earlier
days of universities from the 1200s and
so on
it was much more of a
kind of professional
education
often for the church
sometimes later on for medicine and
things like this
um
but uh law
and i think it was kind of much more of
broadcast education so to speak the
concept of research being rolled into
that as a somewhat more recent
phenomenon but by the time that was
being rolled in and the idea of phds and
things like that that's a a you know
last well last hundred years bit more
than that but not much more than that i
mean well
actually that's not quite right there
were even in the 1600s people were
getting at least in continental europe
people were getting doctorates um i
think that wasn't a phenomenon yet
in um
uh
in the uk for example
but um in any case the the whole idea
that that sort of that that universities
would be these places where where
research as well as sort of broadcast
education happened
um and then there would be people who
would have students
and those students are sort of
apprenticed
that's that's a thing very much like the
traditional apprentice system
it is interesting that
apprenticing
has been less of a thing
in
some of the
well and by the way for example in
medical education um that's again
uh quite a you know it's not not quite
configured as an individual apprentice
to an individual doctor but it's still
the same kind of training type process
um
the fact that that hasn't happened
in some areas like programming is sort
of interesting it looked as if it was
going to happen and then it kind of
didn't happen in a sense some of the
things that we do for example with our
summer school and other things like that
are
sort of a a version of a modern
apprenticeship kind of thing
and and i suppose to some extent
internships although the the meaning of
internships in the world is sort of
gradually inflated in strange ways but
but um
uh the um
uh that's kind of another another modern
version of kind of the apprentice
concept so i i think it's still kind of
alive and well but insofar as the guilds
are not something one talks about a lot
it's uh
that doesn't have that same sort of uh
official status that it might have had
in the past
let's see
maybe one or two more
things here
um
well there's a question from a here
what happened to the interdisciplinary
science of the renaissance
um do the efficiency gains and
specialization outweigh the harms of
institutional departmentalization
um
well
you know
there's this whole sort of claim that
there was a time at which you could know
all science
and
that didn't last
and there was
also the concept of a renaissance person
uh
meaning a person with a a broad range of
knowledge of science and the arts and so
on um the idea that that could be done
in the renaissance
and couldn't be done later
is is a sort of common idea
you know
i think
there's a couple of things to say
first of all
in any given time in a given field
there's a certain
certain sort of corpus of knowledge
and
gradually more things get found out
and there's sort of more pieces of
knowledge that get filled in
but what tends to happen is there is
also more principles are more
abstraction that's that's discovered and
so instead of having to know every
individual piece of knowledge you can
just know the bigger principle and
that's enough you don't need to know all
those specific facts once you know the
once the bigger principle is known and
once you can learn the bigger principle
and so that's one reason why sort of the
the what there is to know hasn't just
absurdly expanded beyond all possible
bounds
and i think this question of whether
people choose to know a broad range of
things or specialize in particular
things
is as much as the question kind of
indicated an institutional question as
an intellectual question i mean i know
in my own case i have tried to learn
about lots of different kinds of things
gosh but that might not be a surprise
given these live streams that i'm trying
to trying to do here um
the uh uh
it's um and you know one thing i can say
about the process of doing that
is the more you know the easier it is to
learn more stuff
because the more you know the more
something new that comes in is fitted
into sort of a matrix that you've
already developed and the less it's just
like oh that's a random fact i have to
remember from that field uh you know
doesn't fit into anything else
um i think that uh and i always find it
difficult when i learn things that are
far away from anything i already know
it's kind of like hard for me to
remember and it's hard for me to kind of
internalize those things
so
this question of sort of specialization
and what that means so you might think
that to contribute to a field
you would have to be deeply and
specializedly knowledgeable about that
field
um and that that would be that the best
way to kind of climb to the top of the
tower of that field is to specialize in
that field
well that is true if you want to make
incremental progress in the field if you
want to actually make a foundational
change in the field it is absolutely not
true
that is
it is
uh the most sort of foundational changes
in fields do not come from adding
another brick to the tower that's
already been built in that field
they come from taking things that were
not
in that thing that was already built and
wheeling in some new idea possibly from
some other field
possibly just an original idea that had
not existed in any field
and using that to kind of uh sort of
foundationally push forward a given
field
but it is certainly if you are trying to
sort of have a a thing where you have
tens of thousands of scientists of a
given type
then
the structure will be such that you
learn the tower you can add another
brick to the tower that's a much more
realistic thing for tens of thousands of
people to meaningfully contribute to
than to say come in with these you know
all these wild ideas from the outside
that's not an activity for tens of
thousands of people that's an activity
for much smaller groups of people
but it's something where
you might have thought that sort of
increased specialization would lead to
more rapid progress in fields i think
completely the opposite is true
that is two things happen one that once
people kind of know
so much within some field
they feel like that's the whole field
there's nothing else there's you know
there's so much that they've learned
there's a whole sort of room full of
facts
and it's very hard to see beyond that
because you're just saying there's
another fact i know this from this area
et cetera et cetera within this field so
it becomes sort of a a claustrophobic
experience of fact so to speak and much
more difficult to kind of break out of
that and see some some more foundational
kind of progress that can be made that's
one thing the other thing is
institutionally it tends to be the case
that once you've got tens of thousands
of people doing something and you've got
hundreds of thousands you've got
professional societies you've got
funding agencies you've got departments
with management structures and all this
both in so far as they have management
structures but with you know tenure
reviews and all this kind of thing
the um
you you've got
a kind of a an engine that's that's
running
in a certain direction
and if you say well actually there's
this other direction over here that's
really exciting and really innovative
the machine cannot go it cannot turn
itself to go in that direction
the machine already has all of its cogs
and gears
pointed in in some other direction um in
in the one that had been developed over
the course of how many decades
and it's going to keep going in that
direction it has huge inertia and huge
resistance to change
so that's something that will happen
when sort of when a science is kind of
sufficiently successful that it gets
institutionalized that way it's kind of
a thing where it's one of those be
careful what you wish for kinds of
things
because
it's it's kind of like uh it's like
sizes of companies and sizes of all
kinds of things the bigger it gets the
harder it is to turn
and
the um
and the more it's just going to keep
doing what it's doing for 100 years or
more whatever it is
uh even if that isn't in fact
the the thing that is going to
ultimately lead to the most progress or
the most interesting things happening
but you know it becomes a thing where it
is very much an occupation for people
and it's one where there are definite
bounds and people kind of know what to
expect and that's an important thing for
many people for
for sort of for the parameters of an
occupation and so that's what tends to
happen
but this question of whether
things you know the renaissance was a
period when all of this kind of
intellectual development and we can
figure out new stuff and it isn't all
written in the you know in the in
aristotle or the bible type thing um you
know we can figure out new stuff right
here we can figure out new stuff
when that was a new thing
and hadn't been deeply institutionalized
it was something where
there was sort of much more flexibility
and much more ability to
to sort of be very innovative so to
speak now something one needs to
remember when we look back at history
is
usually only the sensible and good stuff
survives
so you know if you look at the average
book that was published in i don't know
the early 1800s there was a lot of
random fluff and crazy stuff and that's
like you know this was a
you know
sort of poorly written
irrelevant uninteresting book we never
heard of it now and so we might think
all the books from the early 1800s they
were wonderful that was those were the
days when people wrote good books but in
fact it's a very
biased kind of thing
because
it's only the good ones that anybody
bothered to keep
and
and those are the things that we now
think of from that time so i don't know
to what extent the thinking that
happened in the renaissance
um
was uh you know we know of leonardo da
vinci
we don't know of
lots and lots of other people who maybe
had all kinds of crazy ideas
that
uh
just
you know some of them perhaps should
have survived um some of them
kind of they weren't that exciting um
and uh uh and and
and had we known about all of those
we might have said well there was
actually a lot of crazy stuff going on
at that time and yeah there were a few
few terrific people but most of it was
kind of crazy stuff i'm not sure about
that
um
oh there's a question here
from parmenides are crazy ideas useful
to talk about or are they only good for
guiding intuition and research
you know that's a that's a pertinent
point because i'm about to
go to some meeting about what i think is
in many ways a completely crazy idea
um
why am i interested in it
because it makes me think about a bunch
of things
even though it's an idea which i think
is a pragmatic level won't work doesn't
make any sense pragmatically
um it's still something that kind of
loosens up the thinking process
to say
uh
you know
to kind of consider that crazy
possibility
and i think that um
um
the uh
the thing that um
um
i've noticed you know in because i
do a lot of uh
i'm often kind of trying to
come up with
brainstormed ideas about things and so
on and in meetings with other people i
have noticed that when somebody says
well i have a crazy idea
blank blank blank
that often ends up being the thing that
becomes the winning idea
and because it's kind of like by saying
kind of i have a crazy idea it's kind of
like the the loosening up of well i'm
not don't have to follow in exactly the
path we've been following them
um which may have gotten us kind of
stuck
it's like there's this crazy thing to
talk about now you know another thing to
say about history of science and so on
and crazy ideas is
you know it's a weird thing that almost
all of these kinds of
uh sort of
vague
thoughts about how things could work
that people come up with and put in
fiction and things like this
a huge fraction of those things
end up being
things that at least
have a relationship to something real in
the end whether it's you know the star
trek computer that we managed to build
some version of in wolfen alpha whether
it's um
the uh
oh i don't know some
other
or the little communicators that of
course
uh cell phones are very much like um or
all sorts of other kinds of things
where when there's a glimmer of an idea
of how something might work
uh it often
ends up being real in the end
or these concepts of uh
uh
well lots of kinds of things that
might we might now say that looks like a
laptop computer
well
the actual way things get implemented is
often in detail different and sometimes
the emphasis is different but you can
often look back and say this thing that
people sort of were worth somewhat
talking about
is
not such a crazy idea give you an
example
in our
uh so
back in the 1800s
when people were thinking about
electromagnetic waves where maxwell's
equations from the 1860s 1870s
had predicted the existence of
electromagnetic waves which hertz for
example uh observed
people wondered well how do
electromagnetic waves work are they like
sound waves do they propagate in
something and that was what led to the
ether and the idea that while irish
magnetic waves must propagate in the
ether
and then in the michael simoli
experiment in 1900 or so um was like no
there is no etherdrift there is no ether
and then relativity came in and kind of
explained how things could work and
maxwell's equations could work out even
without an ether
but so then the ether became well that
was an idea that was sort of thrown in
the garbage
um and sort of the notion of an ether is
this notion there's something that sort
of suffuses all of space
that leads to things we observe
well guess what the higgs mechanism in
the standard model is essentially an
ether
and the cosmic microwave background
defines a preferred reference frame for
our universe and we're moving at about a
thousandth of the speed of light with
respect to that
and in fact in our models of physics
in a sense everything is ether
the whole of space
is
what makes up everything in the universe
and space is this thing that has all of
this activity in it
um and you could think of that a bit
like an ether well then given the idea
of the ether people had the idea
maxwell talked about this um
william thompson lord kelvin talked
about it the idea maybe atoms people
were discovering different kinds of
atoms in the late 1800s maybe atoms are
nots in the ether
and then even maxwell had a friend of
his name tate
um try and classify knots
because they thought well maybe just
like there are about a hundred kinds of
atoms maybe when we try and classify
distinct knots it'll turn out there's a
hundred kinds of distinct knots and then
we'll understand how
the um uh how
kind of how they come to be these
discrete kinds of atoms which are knots
in the ether and so on and so on and so
on and people say nowadays they might
say well that was a crazy idea except
it's not really that crazy an idea
because it's coming back
in our model of physics
kind of particles are sort of some kind
of topological uh
topologically stable objects
within this sort of quotes ether that is
this kind of uh complicated network
that's kind of with lots of activity in
it that represents space
so that idea that was sort of a glimmer
of an idea back from the late 1800s is
you know is very much
back again
same thing
for for you know many many years the
idea that there were atoms which had
originated with people like um
democritus and leukippus and so on that
was kind of very much an out of favor
idea it took a couple thousand years uh
before that idea which was kind of a
possible idea about how things work sort
of came back
and um i i tend to think that there are
very few ideas that
have
gotten good development and are actually
completely worthless
uh you know i've been interested in
recent times and ideas that emerged in
theology at the time before sort of
science took over the kind of
the the the you know the the idea of
progress so to speak there are questions
about sort of why does the universe
exist and you know why are there laws in
the universe and so on which were
questions that have been oh you know
fairly deeply thought about in the
context of theology and you know i'm now
back to thinking that some of those
arguments are pretty interesting
so you know in a sense there are
once an idea has gotten serious
development i tend to think that
it's
sort of worth considering for the future
now when there's something like i just
wonder if this could work like this
the crazy idea about i just wonder if
this could work like this in my life
i've just seen so many of those things
come into reality that i tend to think
there aren't crazy ideas now you know
there are things like oh i don't know
what's a good example of a crazy idea
yeah here's a good example
uh brain to brain communication extra
sensory perception that was a big thing
when um
back in the 1960s and so on 1950s people
were often talking about that could
there be you know we communicate by
talking to each other and hearing sound
waves and so on could there be some
direct you know brain to brain
communication people would have all
these experiments where they put one
person in one room and they would you
know have what was it called remote
seeing or something like that where you
know one person would show them a
triangle and the other person would say
i'm i'm thinking of a triangle type
thing you know could that be is that
crazy is that not crazy
well we don't know yet
you know it's something where
you can say oh no
that's impossible
really
i doubt it's impossible it's certainly
the case we know that there are for
example you know the electrical activity
in our brain produces some amount of you
know it's mostly electrical authority we
think we can pick up directly on the
scalp or if it's magnetic activity we
can pick it up a little bit further away
um we don't think
that there are huge effects from that
but do we really know for sure do we
know for sure that there aren't effects
where there's some catholic tuned
resonance of some molecule that will be
a very sensitive receiver of essentially
you know electromagnetic radiation
produced by one brain we don't know for
sure
and to say oh that's just impossible and
crazy is probably a mistake to say given
a particular experiment
look that experiment is no good and
doesn't doesn't show anything that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to say
although even that is sometimes
difficult
um
boy i'm really in a phone state here
well i think that's probably time for me
to go
so um
you